we know there's some part of existence
that's fundamentally strange you
sometimes have the realization that
something very ordinary seems
fundamentally alien-like to us that's i
think us becoming aware of our
sisyphus-like faith when you become
sisyphus who is conscious now suddenly
he's no longer like hopefully going
about his life now he's like forced to
justify it in some way to make sense of
it
dude
i
love your stuff i think that your
channel is absolutely
fantastic thanks
that it's it's one of my favorite things
on the internet for the people that
don't know it's like stories of old
youtube channel
how do you describe let's say you meet
someone at a party and they say oh you
do youtube
yeah what do you youtube about what do
you say it's the worst question it
depends on the person like how familiar
they are with the youtube space
if i can see like they're like a normal
person who doesn't have like the super
high awareness about what youtube means
i'll just say like
i make short documentaries like or
something like that
um sometimes i'll just say like i'll
make video essays and
of course people ask like oh what's a
video essay and then it's
it's like an essay but except it has
video with it
and it depends you can have to quickly
like sense uh
if a person is like really interested or
if it was just
asking out of politeness so
um yeah depending on how they
on their attitude i will expand more or
elaborate more on
um
i think that the more complicated answer
would be like i'll
say that it's a combination between like
examining philosophy and doing media
analysis and sort of
exploring the relation between the two
yeah i've had the uh so what's your
podcast about question
100 times since i've
been in austin and uh
i i still i'm yet to come up with a good
succinct answer that isn't
five minutes long and someone didn't
want the five minute long answer they
wanted me to say oh it's about ultimate
frisbee or it's about world of warcraft
or it's about porn or something um like
they they just wanted like a one-word
answer i'm sorry
i can't give you that so tie together
what's is there a common thread that
does tie together
all of the videos that you do or is it
just your
whatever your curiosity has in store
that day
um
i think
what the channel name originally
referred to like stories of old is the
idea that
you have movies which is relatively
speaking a new form of art like it's
been around for like
just over a century
video games as well it's even newer and
then
the idea was that even those new forms
of art they still have or still carry
like the timeless wisdom
like the stories of old you know
so that's kind of when i what i set out
to do that was sort of the premise of
the channel that i wanted to
kind of get a sense of the timeless
within the
contemporary art forms and also that in
doing so like explore
why i'm still so
why i'm so drawn to
all these things like why
do certain movies become like my
favorite movies like why do they evoke
like deep emotions within me or why do
films from filmmakers like far away
resonate with me like very strongly even
though i share nothing with them like on
the surface level and so yeah that's
uh that's kind of how it came to be and
i think that's an element that keeps
being like a cornerstone of the videos
i think that a big part of it at least
for me and from the buddies that i've
shield your content to as well
uh one of the reasons that it's
enjoyable is that
digging into the real
discomfort sort of the
very normal very comfortable very banal
existential
uh anime
that is a byproduct of just being a
human and very well may have been for
the last
you know 50 000 years but feels like
a very uh particular uh distillation of
that now um you know really allowing to
sit with that discomfort i think is
something that's very interesting so one
of the
topics that you talk about a lot is
heroic stories and heroism and things
like that
there's one hero
in every story but everybody that
watches the story kind of presumes that
it's us that's supposed to play that
role
do you think that there is a
problem in being too
heavily reliant or
putting heroic stories up on a pedestal
because of that reason
um
it definitely can be um
but
um
yeah i i think it's understandable too
so even though i would point it out as
problematic i wouldn't say like
it's immediately like a judgment of
humanity because i do believe that we
are naturally like
um egocentric like we literally see the
world from only our own perspective so
naturally like we
experience ourselves as the center like
the center of the universe like almost
literally like the world to us like the
world revolves around like
ourselves and our like our emotions our
feelings like everything around us
um
is sort of geared towards us and we
uh
like like we don't also we don't have
access to like other people's minds like
we everything else has to be
communicated to us
um so in that sense it makes sense it's
perfectly logical that we see
ourselves as a central character as a
central hero because of course we also
tend to see ourselves as
good people generally like we like to
believe that we
at least have good intentions or
whatever
um
but yeah and so heroic stories yeah they
can definitely
indulge that
kind of natural
self-centeredness in a way that also
romanticizes it and maybe glorifies it
and especially in our like current day
and age of like social media and
uh having to present ourselves and being
more concerned with the image we project
uh to watch the outside then
yeah i can definitely imagine
or at least for myself i have struggled
with like how heroic stories have set
like expectations for me that i
um
that led to some conflict like in my
personal life in
various ways
you say in one of your videos that
there's a difference between heroic
purpose and grandiosity between serving
others and serving ourselves and you ask
how we can know if we're acting to
better the world or just to inflate our
own ego
and yeah this line
between the two
is so hard because everything's
performative now i had this discussion i
was with uh peter thiel founder of
paypal this weekend and
we talked about this thing performative
empathy
that people do in a way to make
themselves look like somebody that's
good so
it's more important to look like
somebody that's good than it is to be a
person who is good or to even do good
and yeah yeah that
i don't know that sort of meta game
where it's not about doing the thing
it's about people seeing you do the
thing it's not about donating to charity
it's about taking an instagram selfie
while you give a homeless person on the
street five dollars
that plays out and and the problem is
everyone knows that performative nature
of sort of charity and stuff right like
that's conspicuous consumption meets
altruism you know it's it's just
signaling
the dangerous thing i think heroic
purpose and grandiosity between serving
others and serving ourselves
that seems to cross a line into
something more personal
more existential more identity focused
and that's
a bigger concern i think for me
um yeah yeah just to go back to the
first point you mentioned about the
performative empathy i think there's
also
it's easy to criticize that oh it's just
the instagrammer doing it for the likes
helping their homeless but at the same
time if you
you can also argue or like maybe add
like a little bit of nuance that if
everyone does more performative stuff
then at the same time it also brings
that message out into the world it
actually inspires people to
uh to do some actual good like the the
kind of fake it till you make it idea
that we if we if enough people perform
then maybe like collectively we start to
do better
in in actual terms so
it's easy to criticize but i can see
there's also a value to it that might be
uh under appreciated if
we are all like just hoarding on the the
one instagram who seems to do something
performative yeah i think that it's easy
to throw shade at that person right it's
easy to say look they're obviously just
doing it for the likes but you're right
the cash value
of the person who gives five dollars to
the homeless person but puts it on
instagram is five dollars more than the
person that doesn't do it at all
and yeah exactly like it's easy to
criticize but at the same time like i
don't give like ludicrous amounts of
money to homeless people so who am i to
then judge the person for doing it and
i agree i agree i think the the example
that we were using which was a little
bit more um
like close to the bone was we were
talking about the eco movement and about
how
many many people are pro-green
simply because that's the thing that
makes them look good and they like
highlighting the problems of
other companies or other people from an
iphone that was built on the back of
slave labor out in china from a
car which
is still pumping a bunch of fossil fuels
out into the atmosphere you know like
the point just being that performative
empathy can sometimes be more important
than genuine empathy
yeah definitely
but yeah yeah
especially in the context of like
climate change and the green movement
that it becomes like
it has like a whole other layers of
complications because
it kind of suggests that like
it ties your personal actions to like
the whole
continent or like the whole world like
everything that you do has like
connections uh everywhere else
and at the same time you also
know more about what your connections
are like doing because at the same time
we have a more globalized world like the
banana you eat it's
coming from far away or like even like
the the fruits that should like grow in
your area they might be grown like two
continents over and then packaged
somewhere else and then [ __ ] back to you
again
and at the same time you have like the
internet and now you every day you hear
about all those things so you know
exactly like how you're connected in
this global web of like endless
connections and
um
naturally like all kinds of things that
you would maybe ethically be against but
at the same time like
i can imagine like you want to make an
effort to lessen that impact or maybe
better like
[Music]
align your own values with
those implications but at the same time
i
it's also hard like you cannot expect
someone else to be completely insulated
from
the world around them you cannot like
expect them to disconnect entirely from
that web of like interaction so it's
that's kind of like the the quote of
mine that you mentioned like this
there's such a fine line and everything
is so
it's such a balancing act between
wanting to do good having to face the
implications and then not having those
implications like discourage you but at
the same time also not having
the good impact like
overly inflate your ego so this like
this endless
it's this constant balancing act between
[Music]
being
hopeful
on the one hand but not being like
grandiose about it or like being
overzealous about it but at the same
time also i think it's also very
important to not
fall into like cynicism and oh
everything sucks and nothing matters and
that's something i think people should
be extremely
careful of because it's so easy to just
end up in that
fall down into that rabbit hole nowadays
have you got any idea how people can
work out whether they're acting to
better the world or just to inflate
their own ego
um
no that that's the reason i wanted to
make that video because i didn't have
the answer myself
and it's something i struggled with
because at the same time like there were
a lot of things that
it's not always either or like there can
be things that make you feel better and
make your like your ego more or that
flatter your ego while at the same time
doing actual good but
um
i think it's just
one element that
can never do
that never um would be
that's never hurtful is to just maintain
some awareness about
how you're feeling about what you're
doing and
seeing like how
you're connected to certain actions like
emotionally because that's
i think the part of ourselves that we
are sometimes most reluctantly to really
examine
um
like so you know the the ben shapiro
thing like facts don't care about your
feelings but i think it
it very much works the other way around
as well like feelings don't always care
about the facts so
you might be mindful of those as well i
don't think it's constructive to pretend
that we're like completely rational
persons who
gather information make a reasonable
decision and then act accordingly i
think it's important to under to to have
a sense of
your own like desires and fears and
your own biases your own like hidden
ideological beliefs that sort of stuff
um the things that
trigger you like emotionally
um
those things i think are always worth
worth like examining and um
so yeah i guess that's
as good to start as any well i think
that is the temptation of the rational
movement right that people thought that
if they became the most educated on
cognitive biases and they were able to
identify all of the different ways that
their thinking might be flawed that they
would actually be able to shortcut the
system itself but
the jonathan hate example of the rider
on the back of an elephant is like you
you get to see this tiny little
two percent sliver of what's going on
and then the rest of it is just running
on autopilot yeah okay so i'm just at
the mercy of most of these things and i
i went to this um you know scott
alexander right from slate star codex or
astral codex10 he's this blogger very
famous blogger
big rationalist guy
and he held a meet-up in austin and i
went to it and somebody asked him
something along the lines of um i i
don't even think he asked about it i
think he just said out of out of the
blue
um there was a period where we all
thought
that we could fix our lives through
rationalism right through the
rationalist movement um
and it turns out that isn't true
and i was like that's really interesting
because daniel kahneman that wrote
thinking fast and slow he was on stage
with sam harris
five or six years ago and sam said sir
daniel
you're a nobel prize winner one of the
most preeminent psychologists on the
planet that understands the way that the
human brain works after decades and
decades at the cutting edge of this
research are you any closer to being a
more rational human being and daniel
just went
not really anything right okay so this
is the guy roy baumeister talks about
his willpower you know like the guy that
wrote the the book on willpower and you
think well
if that's the case if more knowledge
isn't necessarily the solution
then
it is something else and accepting the
fact that
feelings are going to continue to just
plow through
however much logic you try to throw at
it and and trying to um
trying to hold on to that
as a place of wisdom as opposed to
something to kind of be ashamed of i
actually had this uh this concept that i
wanted to teach you about i thought that
this would be
up your street and it's about right here
so i spoke about this on my newsletter a
couple of months ago about about a year
ago and um then i released it the other
week and yet again every time i talk
about it people love it it's called the
inner citadel right so it's uh isaiah
berlin
is the first guy that came up with this
so i'm just going to read you a little
passage here so is that true when the
natural road toward human fulfillment is
blocked human beings retreat into
themselves become involved in themselves
and try to create inwardly that world
which some evil fate has denied them
externally if you cannot obtain from the
world that which you really desire you
must teach yourself not to want it if
you cannot get what you want you must
teach yourself to want what you can get
this is a very frequent form of
spiritual retreat in depth into a kind
of inner citadel in which you try to
lock yourself up against all the fearful
ills of the world and a simpler example
from my friend rob is if your leg is
wounded then you can try to treat the
leg and if you can't treat the leg you
cut it off and announce that the desire
for legs is misguided and must be
subdued
basically if you can't win the game yeah
then you stop playing say that you never
cared about the game and then create
your own game with rules that you can
more easily win at and i think that this
is what's happening with the rationalist
movement in part don't get me wrong i
love cognitive pisces fs.blog shane
parish who's been on the show all that
stuff's great but
there is like a cold comfort of
rationality
that yes that insulates people from
having to feel things
and i think that's where this comes from
and the funny thing too is that
if when you look at those people who are
like the loudest about
being about the facts and the truth and
the rationality
they're like also they tend to be the
people who are most obviously driven by
like emotional responses like
but it's
yeah it's
it can be like an interesting phenomenon
to me
i find it i find it fascinating to see
how
the interchange between the fact that we
have the opportunity to to know so much
right we have the opportunity to kind of
wrangle the world into what it is but
the fact that we can't get away from our
emotions the tension between those two
things is funny because we think well
hang on science has let us go to the
moon and it's cured some diseases and
it's done all of this other stuff we can
communicate around the globe
why can't i be the one that's in control
of my emotions or my internal state or
my fears or my insufficiency or my ego
or my desire for more or whatever
am i not yeah and i think that that's
something that we
kind of
distaste we have distaste for too
yeah it's like
you're reaching certain limitations
within yourself in the same way that you
might reach like limitations in the
external world which
can be it's like an existential
realization in some way like
the idea that maybe if you're like have
a tendency towards like jealousy or like
envy that
that that might not be something that
goes away like no matter how
much you try to let it go or like
even like try to feed into it like try
to get all the things that you would
want or otherwise be envious about then
it's it's still gonna be there like
there's certain
character traits that i think you just
carry with you and that um
you just have to
deal with in some way or another
but in that in that sense i would say
like it's the best to have it like right
at the surface where you can keep an eye
on it instead of just repressing it down
and waiting for it to like come up
unexpectedly
uh probably at the moment that's least
convenient
yeah there's a bit that you said here
talking about the um
the fact that
everybody is kind of fundamentally alone
everybody
tries to
let the people around them understand
themselves as best as they can
but when we really really do genuinely
try to open up that's often when we sort
of stumble over our own words and full
face yeah flat on the floor um you've
got this quote from david foster wallace
that saves everybody is identical in
their secret unspoken belief that way
deep down they are different from
everyone else
um
i think that comes david foster wallace
is also someone who was really conscious
about people having this
egocentric
human condition sort of like nature of
their character like
[Music]
yeah i think that's
that's the part where he says like
that we experience the world as from our
like
point of view like literally like we are
at the center of our universe and
um
i think the the author ernest becker he
also goes into that like with real
poetic language as well like you
you are like in touch with yourself with
such like
wealth and depth and you feel like
complicated emotions and complex
thoughts and like contradicting ideas
but it's it's much more difficult to get
a sense of those like
uh in another person like it's easy to
see another person almost literally like
as less human than you because you
uh
you see maybe like a handful of like
surface level
traits that they have and then you kind
of cut it off you don't deny them or you
tend to deny the other people like
from having the same
depth that is within you so
um
yeah i think that's what
that
sort of means to me like you
um
i guess it's also an issue of like
empathy like the limits of empathy like
you can try to understand other people
but at some point
um especially if you're not making a
conscious effort to like understand
others it's easy to like cut them off at
some point like instead of
in in terms of like character depth and
we don't even understand our own
emotional states
you know yeah how how do you hope to
truly be able to understand
somebody else and
the nuance to their very personal type
of suffering
when you can't even put into words your
own suffering
yeah that's
very much true yeah
yeah for me i always like i like to
compare like the
depths of like the human heart or the
soul or whatever you want to
call it like to just basically like the
the
nature of the universe itself like
i think that the most smallest depth
within you it's like compared to
comparable to like the
grandest mystery of the universe in the
sense that we can understand like a lot
about it but we can never quite touch
that
ultimate essence that it's that's at the
heart of things
um
but at the same time that may very well
be like a projection that we cast onto
it maybe there isn't some secret like
unconscious hidden death maybe like all
the
the things we see and feel it's just
that is all it is yeah yeah yeah which
is kind of even more terrifying yeah
have you seen the the movie drive my car
the the one that won the oscar for best
foreign film no it's a japanese film
it's it's a three hour
movie about basically this guy who i
won't go into spoilers too much but this
is like the premise
um
he it has a long introduction when we
use in which you see the life of a guy
who
apparently knows that his wife is
cheating on him and then the wife
suddenly dies before he
confronts her about it so it leaves him
like with this
gaping hole with
not understanding his wife and why she
did what she did and
and there's a point later on where
another character like he of course he's
like trying to get into the depths of
her and like what he
trying to figure out what it is that he
doesn't get about
or what he was missing maybe or what he
didn't provide for her that maybe cast
her to do that and then at some point
there's another character that kind of
points out like maybe there's not maybe
there's no secret maybe that's just
maybe she loved you and she went with
other guys as well or something like
that
and that to me got me
thinking about
yeah maybe there is
maybe we try to overanalyze it sometimes
like we can
um
i feel that's also a thing that happens
a lot with people who actively go in
search of their self like they go to
some retreat or like on some journey
like they want to discover it like some
hidden essence within them that they
feel out of touch with but maybe
that's part of the issue maybe there's
nothing like
maybe the whole idea of having one like
solid center somewhere hidden within you
is
uh kind of an allusion to like maybe
that's something we project or that we
for some reason or another like
symbolize and project within ourselves
but yeah
that's
even more scary to me
the idea that
there isn't you know the
egoic-less
infinite
hole of peace that is to be found
that the the conflict that you have that
you're riding on a daily basis is just
that's what it is and you're right
i always think about um you know when
there's missing people
someone's daughter has gone missing or
whatever and it's been
four years and the mother's still
unable to hold a press conference
without breaking down in tears and what
do they always say they say i just want
to know
right what they want is to close that
loop and i wonder whether the
um
let's say
with a thought experiment that there is
there are certain uh disjointed
discordant elements of ourselves right
that just do not mesh together the fact
that we want to do certain things and
yet our nature or our predisposition or
our programming pulls us away from doing
them we don't want to eat the cookie
because we want to lose weight but then
we also want to have the cookie right
let's say that there isn't anything
deeper
than that yeah let's say that there is
no way to close that loop right the
missing person the missing cookie
doesn't come back and we don't find out
where it went we don't find out why we
wanted it
that's
that's
almost like that when thinking about
that makes me feel
even more scared by it yeah because
otherwise in the first example or in the
cookie example you can say like
if you have to the one hand i want the
cookie but i also like i want to be
disciplined because i don't want to lose
weight and then you of course you hope
like one of those especially like the
latter one is connected to like your
true self or like your true desire and
the other one is just an obstacle that
you have to overcome but yeah
so yeah i can imagine if that
if that true self is not there then it's
really just the two desires that uh what
the [ __ ] virtue you know what does
that mean what does it mean about who
you are
maybe you are the cookie eater more than
you are the discipline
but i think even without that sense of
like a true self you can still choose to
not eat the cookie it's just
i feel like you can still like choose to
you still have that freedom to
feed one desire over another and
that's i guess the
even without in essence there's still
like a guiding sort of consciousness or
an awareness that can choose between
like what am i trying to feed or what am
i trying to like
avoid or like
have there be less of
there's a uh i want to go back to what
you said before because i've had this
sort of sense for a little while and i
really really i really love the idea
that there's a
an imbalance between how much we're
going to see of ourselves
ie
everything uh and how much we're going
to see of everybody else
relatively nothing and the fact that
there is this huge imbalance in the
richness of our own experience
and yet
we get to see this
we only get to see what other people are
aware of that they choose to communicate
that we're around to be able to see
at the right time when we were paying
attention
you know you just filter down all of
this stuff and i i do think you're right
like that true empathy when you look at
it that way you go
how are you even supposed to begin to
understand
somebody else i mean so what do you
think with that is it possible to ever
truly know another person
um
i think well enough but to add another
layer to what you just said like this
uh to just drop another movie there was
the recent one uh the worst person in
the world i'm not sure if you're
familiar with that one it's a danish
film
um
it also it's about this woman who's in
her 30s and she's also kind of
struggling through life and existence
and her relationships and stuff
and again without spoiling too much too
much at one point a
person is
on his deathbed and he
says to her like
when i die i i don't know the exact
quotes but
um it was an ex-lover and he
he says like when i die i'm gonna
take some part of you with me because
there's things that i know about you
like little details that you have
probably forgotten or like moments that
they've shared that she doesn't remember
but he does and he's taking that
with him in death
and that's kind of i thought that was
such an interesting reversal of the idea
like we're trying to get to know
other people but in the same sense where
we can lose ourselves like or we give
little pieces of ourselves to others
that they then maybe
keep to themselves that we sort of
that we lose for ourselves but that
others keep for us
um
which i that was
strangely uplifting to me
i don't know what you're thinking about
it but it's dude i just keep on getting
existential terror by all of these yeah
these situations but you're right there
is something
that we get to do
and and also you know when somebody
leaves
by definition they're no longer here to
be themselves to be able to see
themselves and yet you have a part of
them
that's within you do you remember you've
seen you've done a bunch of maybe even
more than one review of interstellar
right oh yeah yeah and in that
do you remember the the discussion
that they're having
uh when they're going to make their
final decision about which planet to go
to and they're saying look he's not
going to be there there's no chance that
he's there
uh and they start having this debate
about evolution about why is it that we
love people that have already passed or
that are no longer with us do you
remember this oh yeah yeah very clearly
yeah
so that
what i mean what does that mean to you
what does that section mean to you when
they're talking about the fact that
she's lost this person he's gone to
somewhere else and she knows that he's
there and she can't explain to anybody
why she knows she's there and one of the
guys tries to explain it away with the
rational thing about oh it's just pair
bonding and it's a way to he's the group
together and blah blah and she goes no
it's not there's something going on
uh yeah actually that my last video was
on christopher nolan so i re-watched
interstellar not too long ago for that
so yeah that the scene is kind of fresh
in my memory
um
as a like sci-fi concept i thought that
was interesting in the way that
um
[Music]
the the character it's anne hathaway
character she's kind of arguing for like
i'm feeling this longing towards this
person and i think that should influence
like my rational decision decision even
if i don't understand why
and then there's of course matthew
mcconaughey's character who at that
point is like more they
did the quote-unquote reasonable
person who says like no
that's kind of silly because that's not
a rational concept like love doesn't
definitely has a function he says it's
for like child rearing and like
uh later on the matt damon character
he's also like
speaks of love as a survival tool like
if you're like struggling then you think
about your loved ones because that gives
you that extra push to keep going so
that's
the film does offer like a lot of
reasons to
um
why love is just basically this
chemical in the brain as like the
rational sometimes say like it's it's it
has a function it's evolutionary it's
nothing more beyond that but um
i think
the way the film
tries to
not necessarily dismiss that but at
least add to that that it's no it's all
that but it's also more is the way then
that ultimately the whole blood revolves
or succeeds because of
a more intangible connection to love
like
um
i think it's fine if we spoil the movie
right i think a lot of people have seen
it
because murph at that point she feels
drawn to
her like
old bedroom with the ghost and
at that point i'm pretty sure she knows
that her dad isn't coming back like
i'm guessing everyone on earth they
understand that either they are all gone
or they are dead and either way there's
no
her dad is not coming home
um
but then she goes back for that watch
anyway and that's
also why
matthew mcconaughey's character he makes
that decision to like
he codes it into the the data or
whatever they need for the plot like
that's coded into the watch
with the sole reason that like heath
has faith that she will return for that
watch because
that's
of all the elements within that room
that he has access to that's
the connection there that's the
that's loved that's that's the one thing
that binds
everything together there so
um
yeah i think it's just
i think i thought it actually was a nice
suggestion in the way that it shows that
love might be a more guiding
element than we appreciate it or then
that can be appreciated in rational
terms
um or more like a guiding light or a
driving force or whatever you want to
call it
um
so yeah any if you go even more science
fiction about it like i i personally
like the idea just as like a thought
experiment that love is like
maybe
part of like a sort of higher
consciousness that's multi-dimensional
so that we
that's something that the filmmaker
turns malek also
kind of hinted at in his film the thin
red line
where one of the characters at one point
uh questions like maybe there's one big
soul that everyone's a part of like oh
everyone's just different faces of the
same man
and
now i wouldn't like
it's not like a belief that i have
literally but i do like the idea of
because we especially because we know so
little about multiple dimensions and
multiverses and whatever like
possibilities that there are out there
that maybe like our consciousness is
some in some way like also existing in
another sliver of reality that we don't
have access to what doesn't pan psychism
kind of begin to take this
one step toward actually being reality
that the argument from pan psychism is
that
everything has
consciousness baked into it
but
it only manifests in particular ways in
particular places that consciousness is
a fundamental
element of the universe and if that's
the case and we can't measure it then
who knows
where it goes to um
yeah i
another thing that i always think about
that's kind of one of these imbalances
between
how much we can see of ourselves how
much we can never know of other people
is the fact that we're a finite creature
that's surrounded by infinite complexity
but the depth that we're able to go to
inside of ourselves is also infinite so
we're a
finite infinite creature
surrounded by infinite complexity that
we only have a finite ability to reach
and
all of that sort of mixed together just
makes me think well
why wouldn't you be
scared or confused or
alone or
worried or concerned or in
solidarity on in solitude whatever it is
all of these different things all of
these experiences seem to make sense to
me
because you have like this para a
paradox you're a paradox living inside
of a paradox
yeah
yeah that's pretty much the ernest
becker's
thesis like you know
we are like half guard have
fleshy structure that slowly decays and
ultimately dies
um
or like have symbolic have physical yeah
yes some interesting ways of phrasing it
but
um
yeah i think that's that's
one of the things that i still
that i still feel drawn towards because
i haven't like
encount i haven't yet accounted like a
good counter argument for that or
someone who really frames it differently
or
articulates it in a significantly
different way but
yeah i think he perfectly captures that
the idea of being
having two elements that are
fundamentally incompatible
within us and that we somehow
have to make sense of without destroying
each other in the process because that's
he in his book he kind of points out
like how
how how this
human condition can drive us
basically insane in some ways or at
least it drives like violence and
warfare because we are also desperate to
like
or just to lay out his basic arguments
that we are basically trying to
symbolically transcend what we cannot
transcend physically
so he says like okay we there's a part
of us that fears
death like if you chase after an animal
it will like go into this death
defying response it will chase
it will
like flee away and then we basically do
the same but because we have
a consciousness that is constantly aware
of like death at least like conceptually
like we accept like oh [ __ ] we're gonna
die someday so to some extent he says
we're basically in this constant
death denying state or this death
escaping
uh state
and we try to do that through like
symbolism or like maybe
true love is one of them that's
i think the the auto ranks um
main solution like we
try to transcend ourselves through
on the one hand procreation but also
through like family members like living
in their memories or whatever yeah yeah
exactly
uh and of course legacy more generally
like maybe through work or achievements
or
leaving something behind having
leaving this world with the comfort that
we have at least have done something
like that although our body is gonna
gonna go away like we're gonna there's
some part of us that lives on
um
so yeah that's uh
you mentioned earlier about uh cynicism
and i said that i'd uh
had no desire at all to watch afterlife
with ricky gervais but then you did a
video analysis of the first season and
i'm i'm tempted to go and do it and in
that you spent a good bit of time
talking about albert camus
what
have you
learned from him or what are some of
your favorite insights or takeaways from
having spent some time reading camus
yeah he's probably my
favorite of the existentialists
mainly because he's firmly like secular
about it like you have
existential list writers like
kierkegaard who i also
think is great but he also is
he has a more like religious solution he
has the leap of faith that's ultimately
like the
um
his his main thing
uh whereas for camus he he's famously
said like i want to live with what i
know and that alone like i don't want to
leap into anything i don't want to make
rely on some
potential like god or
other dimension or some other like
unreachable truth that may be out there
and that i must just have faith in i
just want to live with what i know and
that alone
um
so yeah he
i i'm best familiar with his book uh the
myth of sisyphus
in which he
kind of explains the the myth of
sisyphus which
the guy who was punished by the gods has
to push a rock up the mountain see it
roll back down and do it all over again
and he kind of explains like
it's
it's only tragic if he is conscious
about that fact if because if sisyphus
like if he doesn't know the rock is
gonna go down like he's gonna go up each
time knowing with the hope that he might
succeed this time
but if he knows like this is his fate
like he's gonna do this eternally and
then there's nothing else then
that's the real tragedy like having to
be aware of your predicament without
being able to do anything about it
and so
i think he takes that premise which is
then sort of the
the metaphor for life like we know
we go into this world we're gonna work
we're gonna sleep we're gonna do other
stuff maybe have some fun and at some
point we're gonna die like we
we know like we see the whole game
that's been laid out before us like in
general terms
and i think that camus is mostly trying
to find the freedom within it instead of
trying to leap towards something else to
watch some grander ideal or belief
and
he also really has the
um
i think the idea of rebellion like
we can maybe
we cannot escape our faith but we can
rebel against it
which
um
i thought was nice just
basically give a uh like give a middle
finger to the universe
and and i i don't have his work like
fresh in my mind but
uh i i do like that idea of just
uh because that's it's a token of like a
very fundamental freedom to just see
this whole universe with
everything like all the
the nothingness that it kind of
impresses upon you like because if
you're really taking the weight of the
universe it really seems to try to make
you feel like
absolutely insignificant like you are
this
tiny human that exists for like
nothing and even in in the span of like
even in the span of like our planet like
it's nothing like there's been millions
of years before us that's a million
years that's going to be after us and
then this scale of the universe it's
going to be even worse so
um
everything about the universe screams to
you like you're insignificant and then
to say like
as that insignificant person like i'm
gonna make this have meaning anyway i'm
gonna find significance anyway that's
a very powerful
act at least that's i think what camus
is kind of about and what's what i
personally also find really inspiring
about him they say that in interstellar
as well though right they rage rage
against the dying of the light that's
the same
sort of look yeah i guess it comes down
to the same concept yeah yeah everything
and so is the line between or is the um
the reason that we must imagine sisyphus
being happy
is that
telling people who are aware of their
own mortality that even though you know
this game is going to end
that you have to be able to play the
game in a good way
i think so or at least you're capable of
doing so
um
like he
you he must imagine sisyphus happy
because he there is freedom for him to
be happy like he can
defy his faith in that um
in that moment
um
i'm not sure exactly how he
wrote it down but he
i think he describes towards the end of
that book like the moment that sisyphus
walks down the hill like
waiting for his whole fate to start all
over again and then if he finds like a
moment of happiness in that
during that walk down then in that
moment he
basically defies his whole punishment
he's still
they've they've essentially failed at
punishing him because he still
he still
he's still able to be himself he's still
taking a sliver of gratitude or pleasure
from whatever this is i had a discussion
with a friend i have a friend who's a
philosopher who and i quote is trying
nihilism as a life philosophy like
consciously just decided he was like
well i've had a crack at a few other
things and they didn't seem to work so
i'm just going to try nihilism
and i was like how is it going uh i
don't really know what you're supposed
to say like what does what does nihilism
is going well as a life philosophy mean
i'm not really too sure but
he uh was telling me about david benatar
who is one of the um anti-natalist
philosophers uh and the argument of
anti-natalists is that
life is filled with so much suffering
that it is basically a crime to bring
any human into the world i think
something like that don't have kids
don't have kids because life's terrible
um and
i i try i really sort of tried to look
at it from the opposite perspective and
i didn't realize that that was part of
the myth of sisyphus that well hang on
you can say that a life of
almost endless suffering which it isn't
like it's it's small amounts of
suffering and small amounts of pleasure
but even a life of with an entirety of
suffering with a small amount of
pleasure in it tiny tiny little sliver
of it at some point
consciously i don't know like does that
cash out it being what better than
annihilation or non-existence overall i
i would be tempted the non-nihilist in
the room was tempted to say yes
and it kind of seems like the same thing
there you know if the 24-hour cycle that
sisyphus pushes the rock up the hill but
there's
three seconds
as the rock lands back in front of him
and he takes satisfaction as he begins
pushing it off maybe that is worth it
yeah it would be interesting to hear
what a person like that would say if you
if they
someone believes like it's it's bad to
bring children into this world like you
can kind of twist that question around
like do you think that you should not
have been born at all like
would you rather have not existed at all
and
maybe if that person says yes like i
wish none of this would have happened
and
i'm guessing he's living his philosophy
but
were you talking but overall i think
that that's that's a point where people
a lot of people are going to expose
their own hypocrisy like
i don't think that a lot of people who
believe that we should not bring
children into the world because of
suffering or the potential for suffering
they
would
they themselves would not have wanted to
have not existed am i saying that
correctly i've not have wanted to exist
yet
in the afterlife video that you did you
quote camu and you say uh at certain
moments of lucidity the mechanical
aspect of their gestures their
meaningless pantomime makes silly
everything that surrounds them you
wonder why they are alive and that is
him talking about kind of the uh
pointless
daily
uh machinations that people go through
right as they npc and
their way through the world um and it
seems because again i haven't read
barely any camus
that to me seems like a much more
very sort of cynical view of the world
and yet you're saying that at the end of
the myth of sisyphus he kind of has
managed to arrive at a place that seems
much more hopeful what's the arc between
that is that what camus does does camus
sort of personally and also in terms of
his right ingo on this journey of
cynicism and nihilism and everything
[ __ ] to then come out come out to
something else
um not necessarily um
again i i i haven't read him recently so
i'm i'm not in the best position to
accurately explain it but i think he
he especially early in that book he
calls out the
concept of the absurd like that we know
there's some part of
existence that's fundamentally like
strange and that's
the quote you mentioned and like some
other stuff as well that's like
it that's
the
i think it's it's also he that
says like that you sometimes have the
realization that something very ordinary
seems
fundamentally alien like to us like
there's some things that
sometimes you just have these moments
where you feel like a little bit
disconnected from reality or something
just feels weird
and that's basically
that's i think us becoming aware of our
like sisyphus like
fate like that's us being
um because we don't walk around like
day to day like being aware like oh i'm
gonna push this rock up the hill and
it's gonna come and it's gonna come back
down again like
like i don't know how how old am i like
how many years do i have left like we're
not constantly aware of our like
mortality and our faith and
all those existential things and so
when he says those
when he brings those things up early in
the in his work he's
kind of pointing out that we have those
moments where it does where we suddenly
do become aware of that and that's when
that sort of journey begins because
that's
when you become sisyphus who is
conscious now suddenly he's no longer
like hopefully
going about his life now he's trying to
now he's like forced to make
uh to justify it in some way to make
sense of it
and i think that's basically the
jumping board towards the rest of that
book
i hope it made sense you also looked at
don't look up and i've got a
closet obsession with existential risk
so
one of my friends messaged me and was
like dude i'm not going to tell you
anything about this film but watch it
and tell me what you think it was about
what do you think don't look up was
about
yeah so for me
when i made the video i thought it was
up or when i went into the film into the
in the first place like i to me it was
obvious that was about climate change
because that's also kind of how it was
promoted like leonardo dicaprio himself
he's really into environmentalism and
he obviously really promoted the film in
that context and i think even the
uh director did some tweets about
that at least like vaguely emphasized
like okay this is maybe the angle
through which we're
approaching this film
um obviously it's like about other stuff
as well but that's like the the main
metaphor with the comet that's
set to strike the planet but um
yeah that's kind of like i went into it
with that assumption so naturally that's
what i read into it but i was surprised
when i made a video about it
um
for context i did a video on
kind of questioning to what extent it
was an effective metaphor for climate
change and where it was kind of like
struggling a little bit or like failing
to capture some nuances and why it did
so
but i was actually surprised to see
afterwards that there were people who
didn't at all think about climate change
when they saw that film so that to me
that came actually as a bit of a
surprise because i thought it was so
uh so on the nose in the way they
they presented the film and then the
film itself of course to me it seemed
obvious but now i'm thinking like oh
it's probably because that's
what i went in the frame
your priors you'd already been primed
for that yet so again i hadn't seen any
of those tweets or whatever uh or
leonardo dicaprio's promotion but
there's one scene in it where jonah
hill's character
that sat in the the white house
and they're talking about
the fact that look you're not taking
this seriously
this is the
asteroid is going to come it's going to
kill everybody
and jonah hill starts listing off
all of the big existential risks and he
says uh you know every single week
there's somebody in here telling us
about it a rogue ai algorithm or a
nanobot or an engineered pandemic or a
climate change or whatever and that to
me because i had my priors and my priors
were making the film about existential
risk about proper existential risk was
that's the nod to what's going on and
even if it's not it was i found it
really really nice that they had that
section in there because i do think
you know i had this big i said this
conversation with peter thiel and alex
uh epstein at
this event over the weekend
and he's talking about fossil fuels and
the future of climate change and energy
and energy costs and stuff like that
and i keep on wanting i love the
conversation i think alex's work's
fascinating but i keep on wanting to be
like why is everybody talking about the
climate when we've got you know
artificial intelligence and and
engineered pandemics and natural
pandemics and we've literally just had
one that's occurred
and i do think that
increasingly hopefully we'll see
films that are more symbolic trying to
get people to understand x-risk
in a more well-rounded way like don't
look up because the fact that it's open
to at least partially open to
interpretation means that it starts to
get people thinking in this sort of a
way
yeah
i had a lot of comments of from people
who saw
saw it indeed as a
metaphor for the pandemic
which i kind of
i thought about it but i also knew the
film was probably written before the
pandemic happened so
i knew that was not the author's
intention um
but it does it fit well to his to a
certain extent because i do believe the
pandemic is a sort of microcosm for
climate change um
uh in the sense that it's a
um
an external element like out of nature
that's kind of invading our like
human society and wreaking havoc and
kind of like
confronting us with our
the way we kind of
thought we could go ahead and have this
lifestyle we could go like have this
global like everyone's traveling back
and forth it doesn't matter but then
there's you introduce this one little
virus and you can see how
it's the same thing with the did you
catch the story about that ship that got
stuck in the yeah now i think yeah how
how
like such a tiny event like so such a
tiny screw in the machine could like
uh
mess everything up like
um i think it was a
it's also such a reminder of how fragile
our system really is and how much we've
actually come to take for granted even
though we probably should not have done
that
it's a function of the interdependence
as well right that
you you don't have society as even
though individuals might have become
atomized everything is very
interdependent and
supply chain issues and problems to do
with you know the
personal protective equipment and all of
the issues that we've had over the last
couple of years
um
everybody is at the mercy of everybody
else
yeah
but we've and we've grown like entitled
about it too like we're not only
expecting that this is the way it the
the way things are but we're also like
firmly believe this is what we deserve
like we should be
freedom is like i can do whatever i want
and nothing
should like impact me and should i have
to not be able to travel when i want to
be able to travel yeah exactly why can't
i see my family when i want to be able
to see my family and not as in the
policy is stupid i'm not getting into
that discussion i'm getting into the
discussion around why is there a thing
that isn't my choice that is impacting
the way that i exist in the world yeah
yeah i think it has
at least for some people like exposed a
how we can have a bit of a childish
sense of freedom like as i said when
you're a child like you're you have
rules that are laid out by your parents
and then you
free them to the child it's like
i can have a cookie whenever i want like
i
decide when i go to bed like
but i think when you're adult and when
you're like maybe like a family man or
like uh
um
like a parent uh or a partner to someone
then
just like you have responsibilities like
you freedom is no longer like i'm gonna
do whatever i want it's
it has you have to like
get a more mature like version of that
to make make it have or make it make
sense in an adult context and so
i think the people who are really like
concerned about
uh to put it lightly like petty freedoms
like they
those are might also be the people who
might need to like have a more evolved
sense of what freedom actually means in
both an adult
context for themselves and maybe also
for like on a collective level in a
civilized society where
also a broader a broader time line as
well i think one of the problems
definitely one of the problems that we
have is that life's become so convenient
recently
that
we're hyper attuned to any minor
reduction in that convenience
the fact that
your car your new car is going to take
14 weeks to arrive instead of 10 weeks
to arrive because of supply chain issues
to get the particular type of metallic
paint and leather seats that you wanted
to go in it it feels like a huge
inconvenience but only because of how
hyper attuned we've become to being able
to have things
as soon as we want yeah yeah yeah we're
completely living within our own sort of
time frames which
i was actually watching a video today on
youtube from the channel uh changing
climate which is kind of interesting
from a like environmentalist perspective
but he
also pointed out like this
that maybe at some point we need to go
back to living more in tune with like
the
the waves of or the currents of like the
planet and so like when you go to a
supermarket like maybe we shouldn't
expect that everything is
always there like all year around like
from everywhere around the planet like
we've
we've grown like so disconnected from
the way like the natural ebb and flow of
that you can that you find in nature and
like the concepts of seasonality and
um
also with work like we we're kind of
working like the whole year around the
clock uh like nine to five even though
it doesn't always make sense like maybe
in the summer time we feel more
energetic than in the winter time maybe
we should like account for that or
that's a good point i've never thought
of that yeah
yeah yeah there's a there's a lot of
those things where we are kind of like
disconnected we're completely living in
these mechanical terms instead of like
going more with like
in terms of like flow or like
other elements that you find in nature
but that we have sort of
uh
repressed or like done away with
in our own lives or in our society well
we never know when we get mastery over
something
what is baby and what is bath water that
we're throwing out right you know what
what is it and this is one of the
most compelling arguments for
conservatism that i can think of the
fact that progress doesn't always mean
making things better you know you can
change things and very easily make them
a hell of a lot worse i think that you
know there's probably a pretty easy
argument to be made that uh
reductions in norms around casual sex
have probably fed into something which
was immediately gratifying but longer
term for most people individually and
collectively
probably doesn't make them actually feel
all that much better and yet it's really
hard to argue again so i'm supposed to
be a free individual i thought that we
had control over i can drive myself to
work and i can choose where i want to
live and i can have a job i can get it
when i want and i can be hot when it's
cold and cold when it's hot why can't i
have sex with people whenever i want and
you go well no you can you can't like
you you actually can but like what you
want to do isn't always necessarily
what's good for you
and
um that conflict you're right the kind
of
feet stamping tantrum
that
is mostly i would argue people just
realizing that maybe the world wasn't as
at the whims as they thought it was
i think a lot of people have probably
become quite and
rightly so you know you've got
uh pandemic
um
crazy american election cycle that
lasted for three months or something
uh war
energy shortage you know in the space of
two years so
apart from the fact that you're a finite
creature surrounded by infinite
complexity you also now have
this wild
sort of turbulent
existence that's going on outside of you
like
now is a good time to be freaking out
like it's that's fine i genuinely think
that that's something that would be a
natural response
but up until that point we kind of
didn't have any stimulus that would have
caused us to do that
yeah it's weird you'd almost feel
nostalgic about like 2008 when we only
had a financial crisis
and then a good like a good decade to
recover from it like now
like like russia is at the border here
even though we're barely getting over
covet so yeah
yeah yeah shit's moving faster man yeah
what i wonder though if that's actually
something that's happening if there's
actually more crises going on or is if
it's also more that we're like hyper
sensitive towards
stuff that's going on
yeah maybe i i would certainly say that
the last couple of years have seen you
know
i don't know whether we would have
ignored the ukraine
russia conflict i don't think we would
have ignored the
shortages but i also do think that
you're right that you've got you are
hyper attuned well the human system
isn't designed to consume the entire
globe's information 24 hours a day on a
real-time basis
yeah and
yeah
i've said this for ages that
the most
competent people that i know now aren't
the ones who are able to
find information they're the ones that
are able to discriminate information you
know so in 2008
we didn't have more information than we
needed
you know it was still
a competitive advantage to be somebody
that was able to seek out more and more
and more because the asymmetry between
what we wanted to know and what we could
know kind of was still imbalanced and we
wanted to know more than we had access
to and then there was one month in
the end of 2011
or something where the balance between
those two things was perfect and then
very very quickly the balance just
pivoted in the other direction and it
was like it's no longer about whether
you can find information it's about
whether you can separate noise and
signal apart
and that's kind of
the job broadly of people now not to
scavenge for more but to be able to be
more discriminating
yeah definitely because it's it's a
tricky thing too like it's very easy to
be fooled by information to mistake like
noise for signal as you said
um
so yeah that's something that i that i'm
probably most
like dreadful about like i see
at least in my country like there's
groups of people who seem to be what's
home for you
the netherlands
um
so yeah there's like in the united
states or like i'm guessing everywhere
else like this increasingly you see like
people who would otherwise be
kind of like maybe individuals or like
small communities or like the fringes of
like
not just politics but just also basic
worldview
but they are now like more getting more
organized and they're also like feeding
each other into this
like it is it's kind of like they're
like they're bordering off that bubble
and
like trying to drift out
slowly like drifting away in our own
parallel reality with
it becoming like increasingly difficult
to reach those because that's something
that i do
worry about and that i don't really have
answers to like how do you
reach someone who seems to have a
completely different
worldview than your own like who's
completely like
not even more like because politics has
always been like in
a conflict of values like you debate
maybe
what kind of directions we should go but
now it seems like we're not
we're not even getting to that because
like we don't even agree like basically
on how the world works and that to me
that's kind of like scary because that's
something that really
that that's not going to bring us
anywhere i think it's a fundamental
incompatibility i learned this from a a
friend who did
philosophy at oxford and he was saying
how people that do ethics professionally
i didn't know that being an ethicist is
is actually a job apparently it is
and people who partake in debating
ethics
they can have a debate about ethics as
long as the meta ethics
that underpin their beliefs they agree
on so you have to agree on the meta
ethical framework before you can have a
discussion about the ethics and that's a
really nice framework that i use moving
forward that's look we can have a debate
about
stuff to do with what's going on in the
world but if we can't debate about what
the world is
or what the fundamental situation that
everything else is being built on top of
is you know if you're flat earth and i'm
lizard people then
we have an incompatible or maybe we have
a completely compatible worldview i
think in that case we would probably go
along but yeah
maybe maybe a little bit better um
what do you watch so
you know like stories of old your
channel which will be linked in the show
notes below people can go check that out
it's awesome uh what else do you really
i also have a podcast now by the way i'm
not sure if you've listened to that
it's called cinema of meaning it's uh we
launched it i'm doing it together with
thomas flight who's another
youtube video essayist
a really smart guy too
we launched
this march so it's uh kind of new
uh it's a weekly podcast that uh each
week we discussed like a single film and
we really want to dive into like the
meanings and philosophies and
the kind of the stuff that we're talking
about now but then specifically tied to
understanding
an individual film
um so yeah that's something that we're
doing well congratulations welcome to
the welcome to the industry who else can
you watch then online what are the
youtube channels if people think uh this
this time guy sounds alright what else
do you watch that you think people
should check out
um
i watch a bunch of different stuff um
like like are you
are you asking me like channels similar
to mine or like no whatever my interest
because yeah just whatever you think
interest whatever you think that people
need to know more about you can chill
whoever you want
yeah okay so there's one
guy he's also from the netherlands but
he makes content in english um
that i recently came across he's called
martin dolaght okay yeah no one's going
to be able to spell that time yeah he
has a video series it's called two years
on a bike if you search for that i'm
sure you'll find it it's a four-part
video series where he
basically accounts the journey he made
on his bicycle from
vancouver to patagonia i think it was
but it was really just like this great
exercise in cinematography and
storytelling and
he is now doing a series in which he has
bought like a cabin in the italian alps
that he's really just just
renovating from scratch and the
interesting thing is it's not really
about anything he makes these long vlogs
but you see a lot of them he a lot of
them is just he
or just him doing everyday stuff like
he's like today i'm gonna
do the plumbing or whatever today i'm
gonna build a temporary shed while i
work on the other cabin
and so
it's a really
to me it's kind of like it took me by
surprise like i was watching it and i
was thinking at first like oh this is
kind of boring like i was even skipping
through a little bit but at some point i
kind of tuned into what he was doing and
it became this
really it's almost like an escape into
into someone's life who is more like
connected to
or more directly connected to his labor
and to
to the world to say it like
a [ __ ] easily
um it seems like a peaceful way to yeah
that would be
yeah that's
he really captures that sense of peace
of like and
he instantly makes you want to go like
into your garden or whatever and work on
something but you're starting building a
shadow back there's a uh a series of
books
um
the name of the wind by patrick rothfuss
and then the subsequent one is wise
man's fear
and uh
that series is written the same way as
the youtube that you're talking about so
the second book is a thousand
100 pages
and dude it goes so slowly like you get
to know this guy's daily routine you get
to learn about the route that he walks
to go and play his loot at the club that
he plays out on a night time and you can
go for you know a good while and kind of
not much happens i mean it's beautifully
written and the the characters are
compelling and the protagonist is really
really fun but
i really enjoyed the more pedestrian
nature of this book it wasn't super
quick cuts yeah every three seconds it
wasn't and then a dragon arrived and
some crazy [ __ ] happened
you sink into the the peace and the
pedestrian sort of pace and cadence that
he goes through
yeah i think it's good to immerse
yourself in content like that
every now and then whether it's a book
or like a youtube series because i think
it's also something that you then carry
with you outside of it like you
when you like stop watching a video like
that or you stop reading that book then
maybe when you're like doing something
for yourself then
maybe you bring that same awareness to
your own activities which
i think is kind of like enriching or at
least probably
yeah i think i certainly found when i
was reading that book that i had that
same sort of mindset i think your your
stuff has that
uh
a similar sort of pacing to it that's
kind of
um considered and and makes you reflect
i'll give you the best thing that i've
found uh melody sheep have you heard of
them
it does ring a bell yeah so they do um
documentaries uh in space but the entire
thing is
uh created on a computer in
uh beautiful motion animation for like
4k the whole thing is insane and uh the
guys that do i don't know who they are
they must work professionally outside of
this uh but yeah it's called melody
sheep and they've just announced they do
a trailer before the full-length films
get released and they've just released a
new trailer about some new alien worlds
documentary that they're going to do and
it's
outstanding like the fact that it's on
youtube is completely disgusting it's
the the some of them
the sound editing is great the
narration's brilliant the script writing
is really good it's genuinely
interesting and you learn a ton of
different stuff so they did this one
about um how life could have evolved on
different planets and stuff like that uh
and you're compelled to watch but the
main thing is it it looks like
interstellar you know like it's
so
spectacular so those that's too uh you
said two years on a bike we'll find your
guy
and
melody sheep from me will find mine and
if people want to get started the uh
alien worlds i think it's called is a
series that they can get cracking with
sounds good nope tom i really appreciate
you man i love the work that you do i
hope that you continue to do it like
stories of old will be linked in the
show notes below if people want to find
out other bits that you do online why
should they go
um
i don't really have a website or
anything i have a patreon page that also
links to like some of the stuff that i
have like the youtube um
i'm not sure if cinema of meaning the
podcast is on there but you can find
that wherever you're probably listening
to this podcast so
uh yeah you can check that out as well
and um
um also on nebula the streaming platform
i'm not sure if you're you've heard of
that one
let's say like a creator-owned streaming
platform i'm like
uh it's something we created with like a
bunch of youtubers they came together
and they sort of
uh kind of threw our own agency and we
started our own
streaming platform that's it's it's
basically like
uh netflix but with youtubers like you
pay a monthly
fee instead of um
having ads so it's the experience is
completely ad free and so
uh we also get a much like
fairer like share of the revenue so
that's
um kind of the the principle of it and
uh a lot of us including myself have
been posting like some exclusive stuff
there or like extended videos
uh you also see like you always see like
special uh edit video especially edited
videos without like the sponsor bits at
the end
because like again it's completely ad
free so that includes the
sponsor you normally see in the video
itself
uh so yeah you can definitely check that
out as well dope man i appreciate you
thanks for today
thanks what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe peace